on a vu cette très longue audition de
l'ancien directeur de cabinet de Marlène
Schiappa Sébastien Jallet beaucoup de
choses à dire de cette audition il y a
des zones d'ombres sur la façon dont ont
été sélectionnés les associations
bénéficiaires du fond Marianne et il y a
un cabinet monsieur Raynal de la
ministre qui assume d'être au cœur des
choix de ses bénéficiaires et le préfet
qui a dit il y a bien une volonté du
cabinet et de la ministre je cite de
pouvoir décider valider l'emploi des
crédits c'est ce qu'elle dit hier en
audition cette ancien lecteur du cabinet
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
d'abord je constate et je remarque que
c'est une changement c'est-à-dire que
jusque là jusqu'à au cabinet de Madame
Schiappa le cpdf fonctionnait si vous
voulez directement seul et le directeur
le secrétaire général du cipdr prenez
les décisions à l'issue du comité de
sélection c'est PDF créé en 2006 comité
interministériel qui en fait était
responsable aussi de du fond Marianne et
dont le secrétaire général et bien
démissionné cette semaine juste un mot
une réaction à cette démission est-ce
que c'est voilà suite à ce rapport
accablant de l'inspection générale de
l'administration c'est bien ça bah il
est difficile de pas faire le lien entre
la publication non rapport et le même
jour une démission voilà après je ne
commenterai pas le choix de la démission
de du préfet Gravel on va revenir à
l'audition d'hier puisque et bien le
préfet qui est donc l'ancien directeur
de cabinet de maréchappa a également dit
je rencontre à Marlène Schiappa de la
liste des lauréat et sur une association
la ministre et une réserve en liaison
d'un historique assez ancien en
l'occurrence donc une association et
bien que la ministre va décider de ne
pas sélectionner pour et bien avoir des
subventions du fond Marianne de quelle
association ça s'agit-il
il s'agit alors d'abord je ne souhaite
pas d'ailleurs forcément le dire
qu'il s'agit bien de cette association
là nous avons fait effectivement nous
avons questionné le présente question et
tout simplement il nous a confirmé la
réalité de cette comment dire de cette
incursion si on peut dire de Marlène
Schiappa sur ce dossier pour demander
effectivement ce que la suppression soit
que la subvention soit supprimée du coup
est-ce que là c'est pas au cœur de la
faire et est-ce que vous avez pas réussi
à faire une démonstration hier en fait
en commission d'enquête c'est que il y a
eu une ingérence du politique du cabinet
de la ministre voire même de
l'administral même sur des décisions qui
normalement relevaient de fonctionnaires
le sujet ne se pose pas comme ça qu'un
ministre puisse avoir son mot à dire sur
des propositions de subventions qui sont
faites par un problème c'est pas le
sujet en soi ce qui est le sujet c'est
que Marine jappa a toujours dit qu'elle
n'avait pas participé à ce choix voilà
donc là il y a une contradiction à ce
que entre ce qu'elle a toujours dit et
la réalité on nous le dites pas un menti
je vous laisse voilà on va l'interroger
et lorsque nous l'aurons interrogé nous
verrons bien ce qu'il dira sous serment
voilà interrogerait mercredi à 10h la
semaine prochaine autre question on
avait vu l'ancien directeur de cabinet
en mauvaise posture vous avez des
questions extrêmement précises vous êtes
à dire le préfet je n'ai pas l'appui
d'un avocat il me paraît délicat d'être
dans cet exercice légitime sans avoir
des garanties minimales de défense et de
protection est-ce que cette déclaration
c'est pas presque un aveu de culpabilité
non non c'est pas un aveu de culpabilité
c'est simplement peut-être un aveu de
faiblesse pas avoir peut-être
suffisamment préparé cette audition
je pense que c'est quand même assez
désagréable pour quelqu'un qui est
auditionné dans ces conditions-là
fonctionnaires que sous serment qui donc
dit la vérité et à donner ses vérités
sans problème mais qui effectivement à
un moment donné
comment dire c'est poser la question
finalement de la qualité des réponses
qu'il donnait par rapport à la réalité
quand il était pas sûr de lui et qu'il
n'avait pas vérifié un certain nombre de
dates bon on a entendu je pense le
commentaire mais en même temps rien ne
relever de façon de nature pénale qui
sont très très rapide mais est-ce que ça
se fait est-ce qu'il aurait pu avoir son
avocat avec lui hier bah il pouvait être
accompagné d'un avocat si tu as fait
possible bien sûr alors on continue
puisqu'on voit qu'en fait les préfets il
semblent assumer en audition qui sont
gravelle qui a donc démissionné mais en
audition qui vous avait dit que il y
avait pas de souci lui avec le cipdr on
se demande si en fait les préfets ne
jouent pas le rôle de fusible dans toute
cette affaire qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
je vous laisse la question est ouverte
ce qu'on peut voir c'est qu'il y en a eu
un fusible voilà donc elle est missionné
donc en tout cas mais après notre
commission d'enquête notre objectif
n'est pas de demander évolution de tout
un chacun voilà donc chacun prend ses
responsabilités et c'est ce que nous
demandons c'est-à-dire établir l'effet
et que chacun soit finalement
responsable de ses actes là où il les
prend la semaine prochaine donc vous le
disiez vos recevrez Marlène Chapa
qu'est-ce que vous allez lui demander
c'est le cœur c'est de savoir si elle
s'est investie dans la sélection des
bénéficiaires du Fonds
il y a beaucoup de questions il y a
beaucoup de questions il y a
effectivement un sujet sur
l'organisation de ces services je
rappelle qu'une ministre un exercice
elle a évidemment la responsabilité de
ce qui se passe dans son ministère et
donc il y a eu un certain nombre de
faiblesse qui sont relevés par nous
certes mais également par l'Inspection
générale de l'administration car on
laissera pas voilà qui a rendu son
rapport et qui est redoutable ce point
de vue là et donc il y a des manquements
au point de vue de son administration
est-ce qu'elle en était informée comment
comment elle aurait pu éviter un certain
nombre de choses ça c'est une première
question la deuxième c'est effectivement
euh le sujet lié au à la sélection des
projets la part qu'il y a pris ou pas
prise là-dedans c'est évidemment un
deuxième sujet puis troisièmement il y a
quand même un sujet autour de la notion
je lance un projet qui s'appelle le fond
Marianne et comment je le suis dans la
durée il y a aussi des regards qui se
tournent vers Mohammed sipaoui qui était
le responsable éditorial de la
principale association bénéficiaire du
fond Marianne alors vous deviez
l'auditionner mercredi dernier et il a
bien il n'a pas pu venir pour des
raisons médicales vous le recevrez jeudi
est-ce que vous avez la sensation que ce
fond Marianne il y a presque été fait
pour cette personne
en particulier non c'était c'est
évidemment exagéré mais par contre
effectivement il y a eu une attente
particulière je pense
auprès de Monsieur Sifaoui qui a été
vérifieront nous l'écouterons sur ce
sujet Mika toujours indiqué en tout cas
qu'il avait été sollicité par le cabinet
de la ministre notamment et donc d'une
certaine façon on est allé le chercher
au final ça se passe pas bien et ça se
termine par une demande de remboursement
demande faite par déjà par l'igéa en
dehors de tout aspect pénal pour la
moitié de la somme donc on peut dire que
c'est un échec assez assez lourd il ne
reste quelques secondes quadrennale
question toute simple est-ce qu'on est
au cœur d'un scandale d'État
au fur et à mesure des auditions
maintenant alors il y a un certain
nombre de sujets le scandale d'État ça
serait l'idée que il y a une volonté
donc c'est pas des constats c'est des
volontés c'est une autre nature de chez
l'autre sentiment personnel je suis vous
rendrez un rapport qui sera consensuel à
la fin votre sentiment personnel le
sentiment personnel de du président de
commission finance n'a aucun intérêt ce
qui est important c'est le rapport que
l'on rendra et lorsqu'on aura notamment
entendu les principaux protagonistes qui
sont les deux ministres et donc la
prochaine sur le grill de la commission
ce sera donc mercredi à 10h c'est
Marlène Chabat
[Musique]